[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, folks.
Welcome to today's
"Authors at Talk."
We have Huggy Rao and Bob Sutton
with us, both from Stanford.
And they are incredible
collaborators
who have written this new book
called "Scaling Up Excellence,"
which we will be
discussing with them today.
The format, as you
can figure out,
is a fireside chat between us.
But we will open it up to you
for questions at some point
soon.
Before I get into interactions
with Huggy and Bob,
my first exposure to Huggy
was almost ten years back.
And we were both working
with an Indian nonprofit.
And then a few years
later, we again
connected when I was at Google.
And he is a frequent visitor to
our annual PiLab summit, which
is a gathering that we
have every year, where
we get academics from
different social scientists
to come out here.
And Huggy always asked the most
incisive questions out there.
And he would say,
can I be mischievous?
And ask a critical question
that would really make us think.
And so today, I'm
happy that I get
to ask him the mischievous
questions about his book.
BOB SUTTON: He'll probably
get you a couple times.
MALE SPEAKER: And
Bob is a professor
at the Stanford
engineering school.
And Bob doesn't know this,
but Jennifer Kurkoski,
who leads our People
& Innovation Lab,
said that one of the best
reads, that she has ever
had on the academic
side, is a paper
that Bob authored in ASQ in '96.
This was about
brainstorming an idea--
BOB SUTTON: Oh yeah, that
was a long time ago--
MALE SPEAKER: --and she said,
that was the best research
that she has ever
read that describes
a qualitative methodology.
So we're really excited to
have both of them out here.
They have set up this
program about scaling
that they've been
running at Stanford.
And coming from both the
business school side, as well
as the engineering
side, they really
have a very Googley,
I guess, approach
to thinking about this
huge problem with scaling.
So let's give a warm
welcome to Bob and Huggy.
BOB SUTTON AND HUGGY
RAO: Thank you very much.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: So I
have a few questions
to start off the discussion.
And then we'll get into
some of your questions too.
So the first one,
I guess is, tell us
what you mean by scaling?
And why you thought it was
important to write this book?
BOB SUTTON: I guess,
Huggy's looking at me,
so that means I'm
supposed to go first.
So in the process of thinking
about what this challenge was,
it actually was a
pretty simple problem
that we thought
was going to take
a couple years to figure out.
But some seven years later,
we're still struggling with it.
And it's essentially,
when you've
got a little bit of
goodness in an organization,
how do you spread it further?
So it's everything from,
you've got a startup,
being Googley would be a
good example like, how do you
maintain your Googley-ness
as you get bigger?
And also, spreading
goodness across the system,
and getting rid of bad behavior.
So one of the big things
that led us to this research
was, we were involved in
the founding of the Stanford
d.school, or Hasso Plattner
Institute of Design.
And spreading design thinking or
innovation was a big challenge.
And executives were always
asking us, well, we've
got this one group
that's really great, how
do we spread it further?
So I guess the headline
is, spreading something
good from the few to the many.
And it's a simple problem,
but it's not easy to address.
So that's the basic thing.
HUGGY RAO: A very
complementary addition
to that would be that--
spreading good from one pocket
to many pockets.
You can think of that problem
as a problem of diffusion,
if you will.
But there's also another
dimension of scaling.
And that is, if you're
a small startup,
as you grow rapidly and
become larger in size,
how do you actually
scale successfully
in the sense of
not only achieving
a particular footprint
metric, but also making sure
you retain your mindset.
Let me illustrate that
with a little example.
One of the venture
capitalists mentioned
that the difference between
a startup and a large company
was, startups are
like beach volleyball.
You've got two people.
You don't have substitutes.
You don't have coaches.
You know what the game plan is.
You've got to make sure the
ball doesn't touch the sand.
You're playing volleyball
still, you go from two to six.
All of a sudden, if Prasad
serves from the other end,
I receive the serve.
Bob takes it and supplies
it to Cliff, here.
Cliff arcs into the air and
smashes the ball into the net.
I'm sorry, Cliff.
The interesting problem
is, whose fault was it?
Was it Prasad's serve
that was unplayable?
Was it my fault that I couldn't
receive the serve well?
Or was it the way Bob supplied?
Or was it Cliff's problem?
So you can see, when
you go from two to six,
how very quickly it
becomes a problem.
And you can extend
it, six to 60,
to 600, to 6,000, to
60,000, and the like.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Thank you for that introduction.
So given that as the
basis then, if you
have to summarize, what is
the advice that you would give
organizations on how they
should achieve scaling?
And specifically, how would
that differ for a startup,
as you mentioned, versus,
let's say a large organization
like Google?
HUGGY RAO: Let me take
a quick stab at that.
For a startup, I think
the advice that both of us
talk about in the
book is, smart scaling
means that you take time,
and you do it slowly.
We just recently
had an organization
that actually was
acquired by Google, Waze.
And we actually had
one of their executives
come and talk to our class,
and he gave a great example.
They were growing in Israel.
You've got all these resources,
and the VC is saying,
now's the time to expand
higher, higher, higher.
The top managers get
together and say, you know,
now is the time to
have a hiring freeze.
And that's sort of
somewhat counterintuitive.
And people within the company
are astonished, how could you
say you have a hiring
freeze right when you've
got all this money from the VCs?
And the argument
was the following.
The moment you
expand, you actually
are going to get a lot of smart
people with very many ideas.
And since you want to focus on a
particular product application,
you're going to wind up
spending a lot of time
saying no to their smart ideas.
And that's not something
you want to do.
The other interesting
thing was, when
you hire people in a
startup, the smart people
assume they can hit
the ground running.
But often many of them can't.
And very quickly you've
shifted the ratio
of unproductive to
productive people, at least
for a short window of time.
And the third thing
is, of course, you
increase coordination
costs enormously.
So what they did was--
they did a smart thing--
which is hiring freeze.
But they made sure,
during that period,
every single
employee was focused
on one number-- improving
their retention of users
after three months.
And pretty much every day,
you have one question to ask.
What did I do today to
improve that number?
So scaling smartly,
very important
for small organizations.
I'll turn it over to you for
the larger organizations--
BOB SUTTON: --I
get the large end?
Well, I would also
emphasize that there's
a lot of things
that are similar.
And in particular, there's
kind of two principles that
are implied in what Huggy said.
One is the notion that
adding more people
isn't necessarily good.
This notion that many
hands make light work.
And we were actually
talking about this at lunch.
So in 2002, one of my other
co-authors, Jeff Pfeffer and I
interviewed Larry Page, when
Google was about 400 people.
And Larry emphasized how
the venture capitalists
were giving all this grief that
he wasn't hiring fast enough.
And that all of his friends from
Stanford were giving him grief.
But he said, we really have
to slow down, and hire and get
the right people who
can grow with Google.
And I'm not going
to back off on that.
And then, for the book, we
interviewed Shona Brown,
who was quite senior
here for many years
and helped grow sort
of the non-product part
of the organization,
in particular.
And Shona said, we
constantly had this issue,
where people are telling
us to hire faster,
but we had to make sure we got
the right people in the seats.
And I think that's a pretty
good philosophy, , see,
even the small versus
a large company.
But if I was going to talk
about large companies,
one of things that becomes
increasingly important as they
grow larger is-- and this
is Huggy's expression--
is the notion that bad
is stronger than good.
Or the path to greatness
is to get rid of badness,
so bad to great.
And so what happens as
companies get older,
very often sort of bad
behavior or ineffectiveness
starts growing and growing.
And if you just push the
good, and you don't get rid
of the bad, the
bad gets obscured.
And there's lots of
evidence that, things
like laziness, incompetence,
all sorts of difficult things,
just overwhelm the goodness.
So good companies, and
I'll sort of stop here,
they view scaling as a
problem of more or less.
They're always
adding more people,
expanding the more
places and so on.
But in the process,
they're getting rid
of things that are
getting in the way, are
no longer effective.
HUGGY RAO: If I could just
add one more line to that.
The big difference, I would say,
between a small company scaling
and a large company scaling
is that, in a large company,
I would hypothesize that
the larger the company,
the greater the probability
that the smart people inside
are going to become dumber.
What I mean by that
is, obviously I
don't mean to insist--
BOB SUTTON: Take that Google.
[LAUGHTER]
HUGGY RAO: --I
don't mean to insist
that smart people become stupid.
Clearly that's an untenable
position for me to argue.
But what I would say is, that
smart people can become dumb
in the sense of being silent.
And so in a large
enterprise, I would
submit that silence is the
real enemy of excellence.
BOB SUTTON: So
just real quickly,
I was at Pixar yesterday and met
with some of the senior folks.
And one thing that they
did-- because Pixar
is sort of at this
point in transition
where they've kind of grown
up and everything-- and so
Ed Catmull, who is
president of Pixar,
was worried that too many
people were being silent.
And the way Pixar actually
does movies is that, four
or five people who are the brain
trust-- John Lasseter, Pete
Docter, a number of other folks,
who make comments on movies,
and they write notes.
But they had notes
days where everybody
wrote notes about
everything that
could be improved at Pixar.
And it was because they
were worried they had grown
and the silence had
sort of sunk in.
And as they had gotten
larger and older,
there was too much of that.
And that was a
countervailing force.
MALE SPEAKER: The
technology industry
has grown rapidly over
the last few decades.
And within that industry,
there are many companies
that have grown
very, very quickly.
And given your vantage
and your knowledge
of what's happening
in that industry,
do you see the
processes and tools
that technology
companies use to scale?
Are they different
from what used
to happen a generation ago?
Or different from how it
happens in the other industries?
BOB SUTTON: What do
you think, Huggy?
HUGGY RAO: They are
certainly very different.
I mean, if you take Google,
for example, and compare it to,
let's say the median
firm in Detroit.
The way they scale is
very, very different.
Not just in terms of
sheer pace, but also
as you very rightly point
out, the technology.
One advantage is, you
actually have technology
that allows great
decentralization.
But conversely,
technology also that
allows great monitoring as well.
So you actually have both
dimensions of scaling.
Whereas in the older
industries, as it were,
the problem is the
costs of monitoring
are very, very high because
you really lack line of sight
into the enterprise.
Coincidentally, by the way,
our operational definition
of excellence, since both
of us are social scientists,
is not metric-related.
But it simply
means, excellence is
when an organization-- when
people in an organization--
do the right thing, even when
nobody's monitoring them.
Even when nobody is actually
watching over your shoulder.
So I would say the older
generation companies perhaps
invest a little more
in the monitoring part.
Here, the kinds
of individuals who
self-select, they presumably
disdain monitoring, in fact,
otherwise they wouldn't
actually join the organization.
BOB SUTTON: One
thing I would also
add-- I tend to think
of similarities more
than differences--
maybe it's because I'm
an old fashioned,
qualitative researcher.
But when I look even
within tech firms,
it's amazing how--
when organizations
have a different mindset
about how they're
going to do things--
how it affects
a whole bunch of different
decisions about how people are
hired, about how,
actually, a who gets fired,
the incentives, and so on,
and the nature of their work.
And one thing-- and I actually
talked about this a little bit
with your BizOps group about
three or four months ago--
when I think of-- and I already
mentioned this a little bit--
when I think of
Google, I think of it
as a place that has generally
leaned towards generalists,
and people can grow in the role.
And at least, my conversations
with Apple-- and I
can't quote people
because, of course,
they'll shoot me,
it being Apple.
But my conversations
with people at Apple
is-- and I was told
this story directly
by a senior executive-- is
people get more senior here,
they get more specialized.
And if you have an
organization where
you are assuming
people are becoming
more generalists versus
more specialized,
you have to run it in
completely different ways.
And I think that's an important
difference between Google
and Apple, and it doesn't
work perfectly in all cases.
You have certainly
specialists here,
and they have generalists there.
But a sort of exhibit
one-- and this
is what this guy
was talking about--
was what was going to
happen with Ron Johnson
when he went to JC Penneys.
So Ron Johnson was just
extremely focused on,
what's the experience
like an Apple store?
And the way it was described
to me, him and Steve
would argue for like an
hour over exactly what angle
an iPad should be in the store.
And then you give a guy like
that an entire business to run,
the supply chain, pricing,
you add everything.
He would not be prepared
as much to be a generalist.
If you took another company
like General Electric,
it would be sort of the
opposite sort of career path.
So I do think that
tech might have
some of its own
characteristics, but
the company-to-company
variation is just astounding.
Even in the old days,
I remember sitting
in on new training for
Facebook employees.
So this was like--
and half of them
were from Google, by the way.
And I remember Chris Cox,
who's now head of products,
and then head of HR, saying,
yes, you can go in tomorrow,
and you can touch the
code, and you can break it.
And they'd say, we
can't do that at Google.
So the point is that,
the different standards
in companies are very
important for scaling
because-- as Huggy would say--
that in good organizations,
people have a really clear
view of what is sacred
and what is taboo.
And those vary from
organizations to organizations.
And when everybody
agrees, it helps a lot.
BOB SUTTON: As I was
thinking about your question,
what suddenly hit me also,
was the sheer difference
in the physical architecture
between the tech companies
and the old industrial giants.
Open offices and
all of these things.
And I think part of what
the tech companies do
is they provide way
more cues to individuals
to excel than, I would
submit, the large companies.
Let me give you one research
study which actually shows
that when you have
bright lights,
people actually resort
to much less cheating.
Turn down the lamps, the
propensity to cheat increases.
So lamps matter more than
cops, is one simple thing.
And you can go to
any organization
and simply look at, how
bright is the place?
How dark is the place?
That ought to give you
at least an initial kind
of working hypothesis about
what's likely to happen.
MALE SPEAKER: One of
the scaling mantras
that you have in the book.
It is very colorful, it's
called "Feel the Clusterfug"--
BOB SUTTON: It's
"fug" not "fuck."
MALE SPEAKER: --and
the last few letters
are F-U-G, because we know
this is going to be on YouTube.
So tell us what
you mean by that.
BOB SUTTON: You're looking
at me, why don't you go?
HUGGY RAO: OK.
Bob, of course, is well
known to have a tendency
to really aim for very
provocated titles.
His earlier books are inspired,
let's say by various parts of--
BOB SUTTON: The
"no asshole world,"
you can put that, if you want--
HUGGY RAO: Well, there you go.
So originally he was actually
wanting to think of the book
as, maybe we ought
to call it cluster,
and then you know
what the expletive is.
The four letter word
that follows cluster.
And as we were writing
it, the editors of course
said, wait a minute you can't
use something like that.
And fortunately, he
quickly sort of thought
of Norman Mailer, who used the
word "fug" to indicate the act.
And very quickly we
thought of clusterfug.
So that's kind of the
etymology of clusterfug.
Do you want to talk about--
BOB SUTTON: --so you
get to do the fun part?
HUGGY RAO: --I get
to do the fun part.
BOB SUTTON: So
where this came from
is, we were having a dinner with
a guy named Mark Hershon who
actually is a
professional namer.
So he named the BlackBerry,
he named Swiffer,
he's really a good
namer, Dasani water.
And so we were
trying to figure out
what the opposite
of good scaling
was so we came on
this word, clusterfug.
HUGGY RAO: After a lot of wine.
BOB SUTTON: After a lot of wine.
And we realize that there's sort
of three characteristics you
would see, in particular, a
bad IT Rollout at Stanford,
we were thinking of.
Or you can figure out what
happened with Obamacare just
recently.
And when bad things
happen, there's
three characteristics
we always would see.
The first one would be illusion.
That this is going to be so
easy, overconfidence, bias,
we can just roll it out.
So that's the first one.
The second was impatience, and
this is classic with scaling,
we can do this really fast.
No problem.
And then the third
one is, the people
doing it are incompetent.
And that makes
others incompetent.
And to us, those three,
illusion, impatience,
and incompetence, are the
hallmarks of both the causes
and the characteristics
of bad scaling.
And I think that that
happened with Obamacare,
to name a company.
If you sort of dig in to what
happened with poor Groupon.
I hope nobody here used
to work at Groupon.
But if you read the
CEO's resignation letter,
pretty much all three of those
things were raging at Groupon.
And when I look at the
companies in the Valley
that have generally got it
right, they somehow or another
avoid that.
Especially the impatience part
is sometimes the worst thing.
HUGGY RAO: So the implication
behind all of this
is, really scaling up
is easy, but screwing up
is equally easy.
And the problem of course
is when people screw up,
we typically only focus on
what's called, the sharp edge.
You look at a person or persons
and promptly blame them.
But when you really
understand what
causes them to make the
mistake or the screw up,
you quickly realize
there is actually
a confluence of a
couple of things.
One is the psychology,
the illusion part.
And the other is
circulation, or physiology.
And this gets at
the impatience part.
You hasten things, you do
things, you block circulation.
And the third is anatomy,
the structure in who
can occupy positions
in the structure.
So all three of them
kind of to come together.
And the result is, anything
from Sochi, from one extreme,
to the doping scandal in biking.
So you can pick whatever
you want in between,
you pretty much get an idea of
how attempts to reform usually
wind up in clusterfugs.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you for sharing that.
I have a bunch more questions,
but if you have anything
please feel free to
line up at the mic.
BOB SUTTON: We would love
to hear some questions.
Torture us, we love that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes, and
while you're lining up,
let me just continue
with a couple more.
And one of them is, the
role of bureaucracy, right.
And so we often hear
that organizations
grow by instilling a
lot of bureaucracy.
But then that is not
something that people
find very pleasant to bear with.
What is the role that
you see for bureaucracy--
BOB SUTTON: --let me
start out with that.
So bureaucracy seems to
be used as a dirty word.
And to me there's a
difference between having
just enough structure
and just enough process,
versus having stuff
that weighs people down.
And this is a big
scaling issue which
is, when and how
late you add process.
But just to go to what
Huggy's little companies
that-- so there's
a company called
Pulse started by two Stanford
students, Ankit and Akshay.
So we went and we
talked to them.
And they had about 11 or 12
people when we talked to them.
And they were
describing how when
they got about
seven people, they
realized that they have to break
into a couple of teams, two
or three teams,
because it was too big.
Teams over five or six
usually are a nightmare,
especially when you get to 10.
And then when they
got to 11, and that's
about the time where
there are 11 or 12 people.
They're all in one room, sort
of the street in Paulo Alto,
sort of the typical
startup space with sort
of rough floors and everything.
But what they did is they had
them working in three or four
different teams.
So they had division.
And then they each
had a board that they
put with a Post-it note,
what they were working on.
And then every
afternoon, each team
would say, this is what we
work-- they all turn around,
they would announce
the other teams,
this is what we worked on.
Here's the challenges we
need, can you help us?
And to me that's actually
some bureaucracy.
It's some process.
It's some division.
But the challenge,
and this is Chris Fry,
who is now head of Twitter,
some engineering group,
and is going to bring me to
a Commonwealth Club event
with him next week.
And Chris has this
great line which
is that, the
purpose of hierarchy
is to defeat bad
bureaucracy, basically.
And I really like that line
because some time stuff that's
put in causes all this friction,
and that's bad bureaucracy.
But sometimes, I mean you've got
to add a little bit complexity.
And the things he has, his
test is, if what you put in
helps people get
their work done,
but it doesn't feel like
they're walking in muck,
then you're doing
your job right.
And you've always got to
be sensitive to that sort
of balance.
But bureaucracy has
become, appropriately so,
a dirty word because of
the way it's done so often.
But you do need hierarchy,
you do need division of labor,
and you do need process.
Sorry, Google wouldn't work
without all those things, as
warm and fuzzy a
company as it is.
HUGGY RAO: My quick take on
bureaucracy is the following.
I was actually reminded
of the role of bureaucracy
when I was actually at a CTO
forum a couple of days ago.
And one of the
participants, they put it,
I thought, very cleverly.
He said, look, the
great thing about brakes
is they also make you go faster.
BOB SUTTON: He means
brakes on cars.
HUGGY RAO: Yeah.
Brakes on cars.
We often think of
brakes, of course,
as something that limits speed.
But you could plausibly argue,
when you have breaks you
actually go a little
bit faster too.
And it's a little bit
like that for rules.
And the real challenge about
rules and bureaucracies
is whatever you do, you ought
not to increase cognitive load.
And what we talk about in the
book is, if you increase load,
you erode willpower.
And one of our colleagues
did a beautiful experiment,
which actually was a
variation on a theme.
So what he did was
he took a large room
like this, randomly assigned
you to two conditions.
One condition, you
actually had to remember
a unique two-digit number.
The other condition,
you had to remember
a unique seven-digit number.
And all that he does is,
he opens the door there.
And along the
corridors, there are
two tables, one laden with
chocolate dessert, one laden
with fruits.
And lo and behold,
what he finds is,
people who have been asked
to remember the seven digit
number.
They're saying
238-9242 or whatever,
and the next thing you
know is, you're really
kind of attacking the chocolate.
And the guys were told to
remember the two digit number.
They can resist the
temptation of chocolate,
and actually go eat the fruit.
And what we do in
organizations when
we increase
bureaucracy is, we're
actually increasing
demands on people.
Everyone has to remember
the seven digit number.
And then it's no use standing up
and giving a speech and saying,
use your willpower.
They can't.
Because it's all depleted
anyway, and that's the problem.
BOB SUTTON: We got a question.
ALL: All right.
All right.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My
question relates to,
one of things I'm hearing
as you're talking,
is that people who,
needing to scale up,
need to change the way in
which they're doing things,
obviously.
One of things I'm thinking, if
I play a role in Google, which
is designed to help people
learn how to do that,
can you teach
people to scale up?
And if so, what are
some of the things
that are important to consider.
BOB SUTTON: So that's
a great question.
And in the mindset that at
least we try to instill, folks,
is constantly think,
what got you here
that won't get you
to the next stage?
And two diagnostic things I
would start with, and then
Huggy maybe you can jump in, is
to go back to this size thing.
Because there are things
that work at one size
that won't work in another.
One of the classic ones,
and one of the companies
we know very well, IDEO.
For years, when I was
doing an ethnography there,
I would go to the
Monday morning meeting.
There would be 60 people.
David Kelly, the CEO,
would run it perfectly.
It got up to 150 even--
everybody would talk,
there would be this
esprit de corps,
150 was just-- it
was a clusterfug.
So they divided it up, and
you sort of had to do it.
So that's one of the things.
And then the other test is
that, back to this idea,
it feels like people
are walking in muck.
And one tool we've
been using-- in fact,
there's a Fortune 500 company
that we just did this with,
where the CEO basically
put $5,000 on the line
for each of the
group presidents,
is we call the subtraction game.
And what we do is we have
people think about what things
are getting in the way,
and subtract stuff.
And it's amazing when
you think about that.
Well if somebody
came in your role,
which part would you take out?
That can be quite powerful.
You have some other
ideas too, but I
do think it's a mindset of
being aware of what is getting
in the way, in weighing us down.
HUGGY RAO: Just as a
quick little extension.
Given your role for us,
the key thing about scaling
is, scaling actually
has inflection points.
So scaling is not
arithmetic, you
have to really think
calculus, if you will.
So as you move from one
inflection point to another,
what worked if you scale,
let's say from zero to 50
units may not work as you move
from 50 to 100, then et cetera.
So the way we think
about these challenges
is, you may start
out as a Catholic,
and by which we mean
you have a model
that you want to replicate.
But as you quickly
go up in scale,
the option that you
really want to think about
is, how can we actually
become Buddhist?
By which we mean that instead
of actually prescribing
every single thing you do, you
outline general principles,
and you give tools to people.
So starting out Catholic
becoming Buddhist
is certainly a useful thing.
Conversely, in large
companies where
there's a lot of bad
behavior, there's
a lot of Buddhism with
respect to bad behavior too.
So there, one of the
things you have to do
is, you have to be pretty
Catholic about what
the bad behavior is.
Stop that one thing.
So those are the
trade-offs that you
have to actually
think of making.
BOB SUTTON: Good question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question.
At Google, oftentimes
we hear this principle,
and we act on them,
and I know I've
done, is "launch and iterate."
Because we don't have
time to scale slow,
that's the advice you
said in the beginning.
Because there's all these
demands that are coming to us
and we need to act
extremely fast.
So how does your idea
of scaling slowly,
would really work with this
"launch and iterate" principle?
BOB SUTTON: To me,
you sort of have
to decide which things
you have to slow down at.
So you can do other things fast.
So I hate to bring up
Facebook, but I will.
They put an enormous
amount of energy
into hiring people and
brainwashing them properly.
So they can move fast
and break things.
So that's even more
extreme than iteration.
And if you have the
right people, and people
who will learn fast
enough, and this,
we teach in the design
school, both of us.
That's our whole
philosophy is rapid
prototyping and moving fast.
And to me, the question is when
you do that, do you create--
are you doing it in such
a way where it's actually
safe to fail?
And if you're moving
fast and breaking things
or doing rapid prototyping.
To me that's just fast learning.
And that should work.
But if you're doing that in
a setting, where it's not
safe to fail, so surgery,
launching an airplane,
keeping the Google
site running, I
mean if people can't
do a Google search,
really bad things are happening.
So I'm all for moving
fast and breaking things
or rapid prototyping
and the like.
But the more skilled
people you've had,
so the more time you
spent hiring them,
and the more they have
actually shared ideas
of what effectiveness
looks like and
doesn't, the faster
you can move forward.
That's why Huggy's metric, Waze,
is that the name that company?
That their metric was, are we
acquiring customers or not?
So that's what success was.
So theirs is agreed upon.
But I'm not saying you
should oh, be a nervous Cindy
and not move fast.
But there are times
in life-- there's
a guy named Jerome
Groopman, who writes stuff
on how doctors do
diagnoses, and sometimes
in life, the best advice he says
is, don't just do something,
stand there.
And a lot of the key to life--
and this is Danny Kahneman,
Nobel Prize-winning stuff
too-- is figuring out
when you go to
that sort of system
too where you actually have to
do deep cognition versus boom,
we can go on automatic pilot.
So I don't think there's any
hard, magic answers there.
But knowing when
to hit the brakes,
so then you can
accelerate later,
to use Huggy's metaphor is a
lot of what scaling and all
of organizational life is about.
HUGGY RAO: Very
quickly, if I can add--
BOB SUTTON: Good question.
HUGGY RAO: I think--
very nice question.
I'm often reminded of a
lovely Latin proverb that
goes something like this,
"Festina Lente," which
means "make haste slowly."
So here's the problem.
The problem is when decision
makers want to scale,
they usually think of
desirability considerations.
What's desirable?
And cognitively, when we
think of what's desirable,
we actually think in
very abstract ways.
We call that the
air war in the book.
You sort of think it's
an air-war problem.
All that you've
got to do is you've
got to launch it all out.
You've got to do this,
you've got to do that.
You think things are
going to really scale.
But real scaling actually
requires great attention
to concrete details, and
to think feasibility.
So you really have to
think about the ground war.
And in order to
fight a ground war.
As you can imagine, a ground war
also is intense, but arguably
that occurs on a somewhat slower
time scale than just an air
war--
BOB SUTTON: And I would add,
back to your prototyping idea.
So the great thing
about prototyping
is, if you're good
prototyper, whether it's
software or a product,
it's really tangible.
You give people-- do you
want the latch like this?
Do you want A or B,
out of AB testing?
So the great thing
about prototyping
is, you actually
got tangibility.
You're not thinking abstractly.
That's like our definition
of a lousy group of Stanford
students or
executives, is they're
talking tangibly, and then
my buddy Diego Rodriguez
from IDEO, when they talk
like that, and he says,
where's your prototype?
And if they don't have
a prototype, he says, F,
and he leaves.
So tangibility is a big
part of that concreteness.
Please.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question,
since nobody else is here.
BOB SUTTON: Oh good.
Yeah.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: So you said that
you define excellence very
generally, when people do
the right thing when nobody's
watching, something like this.
I think at Google, we
are very metrics-driven.
So we need to define
excellence with metrics.
So what do you discuss
about that in your book,
or you just keep
it very general?
HUGGY RAO: I think
what we talk about is,
when we think about
excellence, we actually
are talking a lot
about accountability.
Accountability actually
has two dimensions.
One dimension is, you feel
like you own the place.
But you can actually do things
to influence development
metrics or whatsoever has been
actually entrusted to you.
The second dimension
really is, but you also
feel the place owns you.
So you need, I think,
the push of commitment
and the tug of obligation.
And what's important
with metrics is,
you want to make
sure you preserve
that feeling of
ownership, and you
create that sense of obligation.
If it's only metrics
that you have-- you
can actually get
to that footprint,
but lose the mindset.
A couple of weeks ago,
there was this company
called Health
Associates, which I
think is a Florida-based company
that actually was indicted
by the attorney
general's office.
Why were they indicted?
Because they were
actually admitting people
into hospitals when there was
absolutely no reason to do so.
And what was fascinating
was the emphasis on metrics.
Every physician had a
color-coded ID, if you will,
on a scorecard.
You beat target, you were green.
You were close to
target, you were orange.
You were below
target, you were red.
And what do you think
these physicians did?
They were admitting
young infants
with temperatures of 98.7,
saying that they were abnormal.
Let them actually get
admitted into the hospital,
because you're actually
increasing revenue.
So there's also a dark
side of accountability.
And the dark side
of accountability
often is realized on the
over-emphasis on metrics.
And we talked at
length about that,
to be very mindful of that.
BOB SUTTON: But I'll
get to what your saying,
but I want to-- and this is
actually very good question--
I wouldn't necessarily directly
disagree with Huggy, but--
HUGGY RAO: Please do.
BOB SUTTON: --but I agree
that you have to-- that things
are more effective-- whatever
the metrics are, when there's
that feeling that, I own the
place, and the place owns me.
And you know what
the larger thing
you're trying to accomplish
is, assuming it's ethical.
Because this would work from
unethical organizations too.
Let's have as many murders
as we possibly can,
might be, for some
organizations,
a reasonable metric.
But if you look at the
cases that we look at.
And three points
in my career, I try
to figure out what
organizational effectiveness
was.
And each time I sort of
succeeded and sort of failed.
And the best I
could do was to say,
in every context you have to
ask the question, effectiveness
of what?
And effectiveness for whom?
And come up with a reasonable
metric in that situation.
So one of the cases
we use in the book
is a group that does
routine knee operations
at a hospital in Boston.
So for them, the
contextualized metrics,
and you have them here at
Google as well, would be,
so how much does it cost?
How much pain are they in?
And how many days are
they in the hospital?
Those are pretty
reasonable metrics,
assuming that they're
dealing with the exceptions
in an ethical case,
in an ethical way,
but I think the
notion of metrics--
I don't think that Huggy
and I would dismiss it.
And believe me,
between the two of us,
he's the one who
can count, not me.
He's one of the best people
in metrics I've ever seen.
But embedding it in the
context is very important.
Please.
AUDIENCE: And probably,
also what you're saying
is too many metrics
could be the dark side,
but just enough, that's
what you should go for.
BOB SUTTON: So one of
my favorite examples,
I can't remember if we
put this in a book or not,
but Jeff Pfeffer and
I, once, years ago, we
were studying Citibank.
And we were introduced to the
most effective Citibank branch
manager in all of the New
York metropolitan area.
So we go in, and they got
this balance scorecard,
they got like 30 measures.
We say, what's the
secret to your success?
He said, I ignore
everything on the scorecard.
And the reason they
think I'm the best person
is that I have the best
profitability of any branch.
And you notice that they
called me the best guy,
and that balance
scorecard is bullshit.
And the other people
who are screwing up
are actually paying
attention to it.
So absolutely too many
metrics are very bad.
I like Huggy's case with Waze.
AUDIENCE: Actually I would also
add that the right metrics are
just as important, right?
Metrics drive behavior.
I think, the question that
I have on the table is,
when we talk about
scaling, I think
you touch upon people, process,
tools, so all those three
things we need to
look at them, right?
And how to prioritize.
And I think you talk about
stopping bad behavior.
And I find that
really interesting,
and I kind of want
to hear your take on,
what are some of the things that
the highly successful companies
do in dealing with
the people issue?
Because you do hire
different people
with different capabilities
as the company grows.
Because the needs change.
So but you go enter with
different players on the field.
How do you make them
work together, right?
HUGGY RAO: Yeah.
That's a great question as well.
So the first thing
about bad behavior.
The very basic finding,
robust finding,
is bad's way stronger than good.
In one study of marital
relationships, what is it?
For every nasty thing you
tell your partner, or spouse,
you have to say five
good things at least--
BOB SUTTON: Or it's
not going to last.
HUGGY RAO: --and you can
imagine the, sort of, asymmetry.
The thing about bad behavior
is, bad behavior basically
is a signal that nobody cares.
And that's the
reason why you have
to actually get to
it very quickly.
And it might actually
have to do with waste,
it might have to
do with delay, it
might have to do with
outright malfeasance, whatever
the manifestation
of bad behavior is.
But the important
thing to realize,
and we talk about
in the book is,
you don't want to
leap to the conclusion
that bad behavior is the
product of bad people.
Good people do bad things.
Because they're mostly
responding to the system
that's there.
And you guys at Google do a
marvelous job of making sure--
when you think of people
who aren't performing,
how you actually reduce
variance in performance,
by giving them a new
start and so forth.
So very important to make sure
you come to terms with the fact
that why are bad people--
why are good people doing
bad things?
And here, context matters.
At the other extreme, what
we talk about in the book is,
people do bad things
because bad involves thrill.
And one of the things
you've got to you've
got to kill the thrill.
We actually have an example of a
nice study done by psychologist
about a factory where they
were actually stealing tools.
So what do you do?
BOB SUTTON: Like big
tools, like things
that weighed 1,000 pounds.
HUGGY RAO: They're
all taking them home.
So you can think of, oh my
god, I'm going to put fines.
No, I'm going to appoint guards.
No, we're going to
have video cameras.
So these guys thought about
it, and they came back
with a very strikingly
counter intuitive solution.
They said, hey, we actually
have a lending library here.
You guys can borrow the tools,
and if you've been late,
there's an amnesty, you
can always turn it back in.
So once there was no prohibition
about taking the tools,
the thrill of
stealing was kind of
lost because anybody
could take any tool.
And of course,
these workers were
being pressured by
their wives saying,
you're messing up the art
and taking up too much space.
Please return those damn
tools back to your factory.
So they were able to
stop it like that.
So those are the two
bookends, if you will of that.
BOB SUTTON: In this story,
I like to use the metric.
They went from having a million
dollars worth of stuff a year
stolen to nothing, just by
saying, here it's yours.
This was a great example
of killing the thrill.
And they would just
steal things that
were hard to steal, just because
it was fun to steal them,
not because they needed them.
HUGGY RAO: The other thing
you have to keep in mind
is-- and I just want
to connect the metrics
and kind of bad
behavior-- this isn't
a conclusion by any means,
but at least a good null
hypothesis.
When there are lots of
metrics, a good null
hypothesis to begin is, you have
smart people who are afraid.
Because if all of the metrics
were highly correlated,
they would all load
into one factor.
So obviously you
don't need 30 metrics
because the intercorrelations
are so high.
And the reason they're
not going to be correlated
is you going to look
good on some things.
BOB SUTTON: I would
also add, independently,
the fear-- I actually
did some early consulting
work a litttle with HP on this
when they had too many metrics.
And what ends up happening
is, in terms of having
the same mindset and
people in the same page is,
the whole game becomes-- so
you're a general manager at HP.
In the old days,
there's 54 divisions
and you're assessed on like
30 or 40 different metrics.
Your job is to
convince everybody
that the one metric
you're great on
is what you should
be evaluated on.
So this whole
political gamesmanship
went on that had nothing
to do with actually
moving the company forward.
Yes.
You have a question here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming
here, and writing the book.
BOB SUTTON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask about the step
before you worry about scaling.
There is a lot of
theories, and Paul Graham
I think wrote an article
a few months back that,
startups should never
worry about scaling,
should just get the prototype,
learn as much as you can.
And I've actually
managed startups
where we had a great product.
We had the team of people
that were not aligned.
And we had the three
issues that you mentioned,
incompetence, the
impatience, and the illusion.
And I sort of said, OK.
Let's stop.
And let's try to figure
out what's going on.
And improve it based on that.
And then worry about scaling.
It's not about getting
more customers, et cetera.
BOB SUTTON: I think you answered
your own question brilliantly.
And the way that we
say this, and it's
one of those things that
is so obvious, it's stupid.
But companies
sometimes forget it.
Which is to spread
excellence, you
have to have
excellence to spread.
And so you've got
to stop-- and that's
why to quote Huggy--
it's a ground war,
it's not an air war.
When you have real
excellence, you actually
create that little
pocket in them.
And especially if
you have money.
Money's dangerous.
And I think you're
Waze example is great
because it's a temptation.
Let's build it out and hire
a huge sales organization
before we have something
that we're selling
is a classic thing
that's happening
in many of our over funded
startups in the Valley right
now.
And that's one advantage
that Larry and Sergey took
a long time for
them to sell Google,
so they actually had to work on
making the thing even better.
And just to give you an example,
in the IT rollout space.
One of my favorite
cases in the book,
at the end of chapter
two, is a great rollout
of medical care,
electronic medical care
records at Kaiser Permanente.
And the way they did it, this
woman named Louise Lang led it.
It was about six or seven year
process, cost about $5 billion.
Kaiser's the biggest
health care system
in the country, private
health care system.
They got it working perfectly in
the smallest region in Hawaii.
They got it just, worked
and worked and worked.
And once that
started working, then
they went to the next
region, once it was working,
went to the next one.
So they didn't spread that
thin coat of whatever.
They got it humming, and then
they spread that excellence.
So your example in the startup,
I think, is exactly right.
And that's one reason that--
probably most people know
this evidence-- there's a lot
of evidence of startups that
are started in downturns are
more likely to survive and grow
into larger companies than
upturns because they-- well
first of all, don't have too
much money, and second of all,
they have to take time
to do stuff right.
And I remember when we
interviewed Larry Page in 2002,
I could not figure out whether
he was the last dot.com person
standing, or actually,
he was on to something.
Because all the other
companies seemed to be dead.
And then there was
this guy, Larry Page,
who claimed that he was
going to grow a huge company.
And I guess he was right.
So I think you've got it, man.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
the core of my question,
and based on your
experience, and maybe it
might be your next book
which is, how do you
infuse excellence
in the first place?
BOB SUTTON: OK.
Huggy you answer that.
That's too hard.
Huggy gets all the
hard questions.
He's the smart one--
HUGGY RAO: I think--
BOB SUTTON: --He is.
If there was an IQ test right
now, [INAUDIBLE] happen.
HUGGY RAO: So this
actually dovetails
quite nicely with one of
the core beliefs at Google
and really your own
experience here.
I think the heart of
infusing excellence
is really how you hire people.
That's one part.
And real excellence
also means, how do you
get extraordinary performance
out of ordinary individuals?
So hiring talent
doesn't sort of mean,
well we're actually going
to get the very best people.
And we're going to pay a
whole lot and so forth.
You can actually get
amazing performance
from ordinary individuals.
And here, changing
the context matters.
One of the cases
that we talk about,
which was actually written by a
colleague of ours at Stanford,
is about a company called
Tomago-ya in Japan.
And what Tomago-ya does is
they deliver lunch to offices,
$3.60 per lunch.
And it's a little Bento box.
So every day you can
order the lunch you want.
The last order is at 10 o'clock.
And you've got to
deliver the lunch by 12.
The amazing thing is, their
factory is more than 2.5 hours
away from the business
district of Tokyo, Shinjuku,
but you've got to
deliver the lunch.
So the problem is, how do you
actually wait until 10 o'clock
and deliver the lunch?
And every day they
serve 70,000 lunches.
And the average
waste, if you will,
the underage, or in
their case, the overage,
is that on 46 lunches,
which translates to 0.06.
My colleague, who wrote
the case, asked the CEO.
He says, how do you do that?
Do you guys have very
sophisticated algorithms,
where you can process
orders, route trucks.
He says no.
How do you do that?
And he says, well, we
make sure our trucks leave
before the first order comes.
And the guy says,
how can you do that?
How can you get trucks to
leave your facility at 8:00
in the morning to the farthest
the [INAUDIBLE] customers
even before you got the orders?
And the guy says, the key
people are our van drivers,
who deliver the lunches.
They can actually
pick the customer.
And once the lunch is over,
these are reusable Bento boxes.
You can go and pick the
Bento box up, talk to people,
and quickly find out what the
nature of demand the next day
is.
And in the evening,
they tell their boss.
By the way, a small
district actually
is managed by one of
these area managers.
And then you'll
funnel it upwards,
and that's really what it is.
And my colleague said,
now, who designed this?
And the founder said, you
know, me and the truck drivers.
And he said, who are
the truck drivers?
And this is the
striking part, they
are all people who are
high school dropouts.
Now, it's true that
there are bonuses
that link to any weigh stage.
But the point is,
it's not just that.
You've given them
a second chance.
And you are really getting
extraordinary performance
out of people who could arguably
be labeled C or B, or whatever.
So very important to
keep that in mind.
AUDIENCE: I'll make it
a little bit harder.
So you go into a startup,
small team, one star.
Most of the others are B's
and a few, let's call, F's.
And you start getting rid of
the F's because it's just not
working.
And then you end up
with a smaller team,
with the VCs shouting at you.
And you're running out of
money, product's not performing.
The excellence, the culture of
the company is just struggling.
And all of the elements
are against you,
as any other startup.
And then to infuse a
culture of excellence
into a place that got used to
being sub-mediocre performance
is something I really
struggled with personally
in a previous life.
And I want to just see
what is your take on how
that could that be handled.
HUGGY RAO: I can certainly
feel your pain is
one thing I can say.
I'm being mischievous here.
But in the hypothetical example,
or the reconstructed example
out of your experience that
you gave, you've got one star,
you've taken out
the F's, I assume.
And you've got the B people
as it were, so to speak.
And one of the
things we talk about
is, scaling isn't just
about stars, it's actually
about your sherpas, too.
I mean think of how you
get to the top of Everest.
Three people get
there, that's true.
But there's a lot of
people who actually
do all the heavy lifting
to help you get there.
BOB SUTTON: The
Sherpas are the stars,
and the other people
just pay them money.
So [INAUDIBLE] the question
where the stars is.
HUGGY RAO: So the real challenge
is, how do you actually
get great performance out of
people who are at the B level?
And one simple place to start.
It's by no means a
sure fire bullet is,
if you look at the evidence,
B-level players respond
way more positively to
gifts that are actually
given to them.
So when I say gifts, I'm
not saying buying them off
with money, doing something
for them that's a surprise
that they actually value.
And the reason is, if
you have B-level player,
you look around in the
market, and you sort of say,
I'm looking around,
I can't get a job
like I have in this company.
Here's a company that's
done something nice for me.
And it could be as simple
a thing as something
for their child or
spouse or whatever
the specific
instantiation is, they're
actually going to
give you 10x back.
If I'm an A-level player,
you do something nice for me,
I'm also going to scan
the talent market,
and simply say, well
he did it because hey,
that's the price at attention.
Otherwise, I'm going
to go someplace else.
So you actually have
very asymmetric responses
to gift-giving.
And what you really
need to understand
is, what's the gift
that makes the most
sense for your B-level players?
And that, I don't have line
of sight to give you more--
BOB SUTTON: I'm going to say
something more cynical which
is, we hear about the--
including this one we're
sitting in now-- the
startups that all make it.
Most of them die.
Most of them deserve to die.
And a lot of the
entrepreneurial game, I'm sorry,
it's just knowing when
to shoot the thing.
And venture capitalists,
especially the good ones,
are really good at that.
And I don't want to
damn your startup.
But the typical startup
in Silicon Valley dies.
And it should die.
So in the thing to do
is to take that A-player
and maybe reform with another
set A-players and to go again.
Because the great thing about
startups is, failure's cheap.
And most of you who start
firms in Silicon Valley-- this
is not Detroit-- you
can get another job.
Most of you are quite talented.
So my view of startups is, if
things are really screwed up,
well that's what
pulling the plug is for.
And quitting is good.
Never quit-- that's bullshit.
HUGGY RAO: And
certainly, you don't
want to escalate commitment to a
losing course of action either.
BOB SUTTON: That's
what I was saying.
More fancy language.
HUGGY RAO: This is the
conversation Bob and I have.
But usually over
a lot of wine so.
MALE SPEAKER: So having said
all that, you aren't advising
people to go to startups, right?
[LAUGHTER]
BOB SUTTON: No, no.
You all know the odds.
You all know the game.
So it's just the way it works.
So you go there, and Google
buys you or they come back,
you come back as an
employee after it died.
Either way, it's OK.
MALE SPEAKER: So do we have time
for a question or two, Cliff,
or are we set?
CLIFF: Yes, a final question.
MALE SPEAKER: Any other audience
question for Bob and Huggy?
I had one more, which
doesn't have anything
to do with the book itself.
Obviously, both of you
teach at the business school
at Standford.
And many Googlers are
interested in going
to business school
getting their MBAs, right?
So what's the advice that
you'd give to a Googler who's
considering business
school, who has
other things that they could do?
And this is a question that
we and the people up scheme
get asked all the time.
So since we have you, we can
ask the same question of you.
And by the way, don't
make it too compelling
because we want these
people to stay here.
HUGGY RAO: So Bob why
don't you actually be--
BOB SUTTON: I don't teach in
a business school, remember.
I'm an engineering
professor, so therefore, I
am free to be cynical.
Our friend Jeff
Pfeffer would tell you
that, if you're interested
actually in lifetime income,
that you should only go to a top
eight-- in addition to the fact
that it's a great vacation, and
all sorts of wonderful things
happen in business school.
But you should only go to a top
eight or ten business school.
Because other than
that it's just
going to take two
years of your life
and lower your lifetime income,
and there's very good evidence
to support this.
So I want to play the,
sort of, Jeff Pfeffer card.
But one thing I will say
about the Stanford Business
School, where I don't
teach, because I'm
a tenured engineering professor,
is that-- as my understanding--
is that if you go
to Stanford, it's
actually a really
good financial deal.
That on average, you're going
to come out ahead financially.
And culturally, that's
sort of up to you.
The final thing I would
say though, since I'm
from an engineering school
and I'm not engineer,
is we all know that
the characteristic
of the current boom is
it's much, much less
MBA-centric, and
much, much-- you
know this much
better than I do--
and much, much more
engineering-centric.
So it's the engineers'
days, and we're
winning, even on an engineer.
HUGGY RAO: So one other
thing to keep in mind
is, business schools are
changing dramatically too,
so you don't think of the
MBA as a standalone degree.
In fact, we have a number of
programs where you actually
have an MBA, you can
also get a masters
in computer science and
electrical engineering,
just to name a few.
So there are lots of
options and combinations.
Our experience certainly at
the Stanford Business School
is, pretty much, the kinds
of people who actually come,
they're overwhelmingly tilted
towards a startup option.
By the end of year one, they've
already figured out an idea.
They're working.
They're trying to do things.
And as a matter of fact,
right before I came here,
I was actually teaching a course
along with a finance professor
and a marketing professor,
a course called "From Launch
to Liquidity."
Once you start a venture,
how do you actually
think of your exit?
And I can certainly
tell you, our students
believe in very liquid futures.
or at least, they kind
of anticipate that.
BOB SUTTON: See,
I don't even know
how he was teaching this,
since I'm very focused.
The course we teach in the
engineering school, especially
the design school, we
wouldn't talk about it.
We have a class
called "Launch Pad."
We put you in it, and
you'd start your company.
And so there's a class
called "Launch Pad"
taught by Michael
Dearing and Perry
Klebahn, both who are
successful entrepreneurs
in their own right.
Although Michael did fail
in a big shoe operation.
If you don't have a
product by week four,
you're supposed
to be thrown out.
So little--
HUGGY RAO: A number
of our students
actually do take that course--
BOB SUTTON: You can take that
as well in the business school.
HUGGY RAO: So you have the
whole, sort of, university.
But just to give underscore.
Bob's point about how
attractive this is as an option.
Once when I was
teaching a class,
there was a young lady who
got up and told everybody
in the class, hey, I
have a proposal for you.
And she looked at me
and said, professor,
can I make the proposal?
I said, sure.
She looked at 80 kids
in the class and said,
I'm actually going to give
you $250,000 right now.
In return, I want 2% of
your lifetime earnings.
what do you think was the
response of those 80 people?
Mull over that,
and that's where we
ought to appropriately
close on a puzzle.
BOB SUTTON: That's
like a Google interview
question, the old ones.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Thank you Bob and Huggy
for coming over and sharing
all of your insights on scaling.
Again, the book is called
"Scaling Up Excellence."
BOB SUTTON: Thanks
for your questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
thank you for questions,
and we have copies of the
book in the back, as well.
So, with that, lets give a
warm round to Bob and Huggy.
BOB SUTTON: Thank you.
HUGGY RAO: Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]